Nous vivons une saison particulière avec l'Église Bonne Nouvelle, depuis quelques mois déjà,
malgré la période de confinement et les moments de communion fraternelle qu'on ne vit pas à la mesure dont on le souhaiterait.
Nous avons eu la grâce de voir beaucoup de personnes nous joindre à l'Église Bonne Nouvelle.
Là où beaucoup d'églises se vident, nous avons eu la grâce de voir des personnes nous joindre,
et souvent avec les mêmes motifs, parce que la parole de Dieu est enseignée fidèlement dans cette assemblée.
Et nous rendons gloire au Seigneur pour cela.
Nous avons même eu la joie, depuis deux semaines, d'assister à des baptêmes,
qui est certainement l'événement le plus joyeux qu'une église peut vivre,
où nous voyons l'exposition de la grâce rédemptrice de Dieu affichée dans le cœur de nos bien-aimés,
de nos frères et sœurs qui nous entourent.
Et ce baptême-là, ces deux derniers baptêmes, je ne sais pas combien il y a de baptêmes,
mais ces deux dernières semaines où nous avons vu les baptêmes,
c'était glorieux de voir comment Dieu a arraché les cœurs durs,
des cœurs opposés à l'Évangile, pour les ramener dans son royaume.
Comme nous l'avons entendu dans nos prières ce matin,
nous étions impossibles par nous-mêmes.
Il était impossible par nous-mêmes de chercher Dieu.
Voilà comment la Bible décrit le cœur de l'incroyant.
La Bible est sans équivoque à ce sujet.
L'homme naturel est mort aux choses de Dieu.
Il est représenté comme ayant un cœur de pierre,
c'est-à-dire dans l'incapacité totale de considérer Dieu dans ses vertus telles qu'il est,
dans une absence totale d'appréciation pour les choses de Dieu.
La Bible nous dit que les choses spirituelles ne se discernent que spirituellement.
Nous étions dans l'incapacité de considérer Dieu, d'apprécier les choses de Dieu
et de décider de nous-mêmes de choisir Dieu.
Mais en plus de cette incapacité, nous n'avions aucune volonté.
Nous détestions les choses de Dieu.
Notre cœur de chair est en inimitié contre les choses de Dieu,
comme nous présente l'apôtre Paul.
Et quand nous connaissons ces vérités concernant le cœur de l'incroyant,
nous considérons chaque baptême comme étant un miracle.
Comment un cœur si opposé à l'évangile,
si mort, sourd, aveugle aux choses de Dieu,
a pu un jour dire,
« Seigneur, je veux dédier ma vie pour te suivre.
Je te prête mon allégeance. »
Oui, Dieu est intervenu.
Dieu a régénéré ses cœurs pour en faire des cœurs de chair.
Voilà le miracle que nous célébrons à chaque baptême,
peu importe,
comment dirais-je,
peu importe le témoignage d'une certaine manière,
peu importe les événements extraordinaires
que nos bien-aimés ont connus dans leur vie,
et nous rendons grâce à Dieu pour ces événements qu'ils ont pu connaître.
Mais nous assistons à chaque fois à un miracle,
un cœur de pierre devenu cœur de chair.
Dieu qui crée à partir de rien,
par sa parole,
tout comme à la création,
il a par la genèse ex nihilo de rien,
il créa le monde et ce qui nous environne.
Voilà la régénération,
la nouvelle genèse dans notre cœur,
où Dieu par sa parole, de la même manière,
a créé un nouvel homme
en chacun d'entre nous,
si nous lui appartenons.
Voilà ce qu'il en est pour l'incroyant.
Et il y a une sous-catégorie parmi ces incroyants
que la Bible nous présente.
Parmi les incroyants,
il y a certaines personnes qui sont endurcies.
Et le mot endurcie dans la parole de Dieu
est utilisé dans un but spécifique,
un groupe de personnes spécifiques.
Oui, le cœur de l'homme est dur,
oui, le cœur de l'homme est opposé à l'Évangile,
mais il y a le mot endurcissement,
endurcie,
qui est adressé à un groupe particulier
de personnes dans les Écritures.
Et ce groupe-là,
qui est endurci selon le conseil
de la parole de Dieu,
est un groupe de personnes
qui a été exposées aux vertus de Dieu.
qui a compris,
qui a été exposées
à la gloire de Christ,
à la gloire de Dieu.
Et qui pourtant,
n'a pas prêté allégeance au Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Voilà de qui nous parlons
lorsque nous parlons des cœurs endurcis.
Et l'apôtre, ici,
dans l'Épître aux Hébreux,
parle à un groupe de personnes,
et nous comprenons très rapidement dans cette lettre,
qu'il parle d'un groupe de personnes
composé de différents groupes,
sous-groupes de personnes.
Il y a ceux qui ont besoin
d'être encouragés dans leur persévérance.
d'être encore plus éclairés
par la gloire de Christ
pour mieux l'adorer,
pour mieux le servir.
Et il y a des cœurs endurcis.
Des personnes qui ont assisté
et qui ont été exposées
à la lumière de l'Évangile.
Des personnes qui ont considéré Christ,
à qui la supériorité de Christ
a été clairement affichée,
et qui pourtant,
pourtant,
ont le cœur endurci face à Dieu.
Et voilà le groupe de personnes
spécifiquement
à qui l'apôtre s'adresse
dans les passages
que nous allons lire ce matin.
Et comme introduction,
je voulais juste vous rappeler
que le passage que nous allons lire
dans le chapitre 3 aux Hébreux
est un passage dur,
un passage avec un appel
qui est solennel et grave.
La tonalité de ce passage
est assez extrême,
d'une certaine façon.
Et particulièrement pour vous
qui nous rejoignez peut-être
pour les premières fois,
il serait facile de se faire des idées
sur l'enseignement de l'Église
à partir d'une seule prédication.
Néanmoins,
je tiens à vous rappeler
que nous faisons des prédications,
nous essayons de faire des prédications
textuelles dans cette Église.
C'est-à-dire que nous suivons un chapitre
et notre devoir,
c'est de vous transmettre
l'intentionnalité de l'auteur
dans le passage que nous méditons.
Et avant d'adresser ce chapitre-là,
ce passage dont l'appel est grave
et solennel,
nous avons parcouru
Hébreux 1 et Hébreux 2 ensemble.
Et ce matin,
lors de l'introduction,
lors de la lecture de la parole
pendant la prière,
vous avez entendu les vérités
à propos de Hébreux 1 et Hébreux 2,
Christ supérieur aux anges.
Avec une tonalité beaucoup plus douce
que le passage que nous allons lire ce matin.
Christ élevé dans la gloire.
Christ qui a été fait même
pour un peu de temps
en dessous des anges.
Voilà tous les passages
que nous avons considérés également.
La bonté de Dieu,
la grandeur de Dieu,
la magnificence de Dieu.
Et ce matin,
bien que la tonalité soit différente
dans le passage que nous allons lire,
nous ne voulons pas non plus,
au risque de faire peur
aux nouveaux venus,
nous ne voulons pas non plus
changer l'intentionnalité
de l'auteur dans ce passage.
Et nous allons,
dans la mesure
de la grâce de Dieu,
rester fidèles
à ce que Dieu veut nous enseigner ce matin.
Lisons ensemble.
Hébreux 3,
verset 7.
Sachant que nous avons déjà
parcouru le chapitre 2
et le chapitre 3 ensemble.
Et le début du chapitre 3,
verset 7.
C'est pourquoi,
selon ce que dit le Saint-Esprit,
aujourd'hui,
si vous entendez sa voix,
n'endurcissez pas vos cœurs.
Comme lors de la révolte,
le jour de la tentation
dans le désert,
où vos pères me tentèrent
pour m'éprouver
et ils virent mes œuvres
pendant quarante ans.
Aussi,
je fus irrité,
irrité contre cette génération.
Et je dis,
ils ont toujours un cœur
qui s'égare.
Ils n'ont pas connu mes voix.
Je jurais donc,
dans ma colère,
ils n'entreront pas
dans mon repos.
Le psalmiste
disait au psaume 139,
élevé cette prière devant Dieu,
sonde-moi, ô Dieu,
et connais mon cœur.
Éprouve-moi,
et connais mes pensées.
Regarde si je suis
sur une mauvaise voie
et conduis-moi
sur la voie de l'éternité.
Quelle prière
humble de la part
du psalmiste.
C'est un homme
qui reconnaît
qu'il n'est pas
tout à fait
toujours lucide
par rapport à son état
dans sa marche spirituelle
avec Dieu.
Un homme qui reconnaît
qu'il a besoin
que Dieu l'éclaire
pour comprendre
si son cœur
est endurci ou non.
et parfois,
nous pouvons avoir
nous-mêmes
des propres mots
quant à notre état
spirituel devant Dieu.
Peut-être aujourd'hui
que vous traversez
une saison
où vous vous dites
lassé
à propos des choses
de Dieu,
fatigué
à propos des choses
de Dieu.
Mais il se pourrait,
mes frères et sœurs,
qu'au regard de Dieu,
vous n'êtes ni lassé
ni fatigué
ni endurci.
Il se peut
qu'au regard de Dieu,
le réel état
de votre cœur
est sur une voie
de l'endurcissement.
Et ce matin,
si nous voulons profiter
de l'appel
que Dieu nous lance,
nous devons nous plonger
dans ce message
et comprendre
plusieurs choses
à propos de l'endurcissement
telle qu'enseignée
dans ce passage.
Nous devons comprendre
premièrement
qu'est-ce que
cet endurcissement,
quelle est la nature,
la définition essentielle
de l'endurcissement
telle qu'expliquée
par la parole de Dieu
elle-même.
Quel est donc
cet endurcissement
qui est en réponse
à la voix de Dieu ?
Je relis le verset 7.
Si vous entendez
sa voix,
n'endurcissez pas
vos cœurs.
Quel est donc
essentiellement
cet endurcissement ?
Suis-je moi-même,
Seigneur,
endurci devant toi ?
Et si le psalmiste
a élevé cette prière,
cette prière devait être
notre aussi.
Seigneur,
regarde à mon cœur.
Regarde si je suis
sur une voie
d'endurcissement.
Et à la place,
quand le psalmiste
a considéré
l'enjeu éternel
de son endurcissement,
conduis-moi sur la voie
de l'éternité.
À la lumière de ce passage,
nous sommes appelés
à évaluer notre cœur.
Sommes-nous ce matin
endurcis ?
Et nous devons comprendre
qu'est-ce que l'endurcissement.
C'est notre premier objectif
ce matin.
Comme les membres
de l'Église
le savent déjà,
nous avons eu
la triste expérience
récemment
de connaître
le premier cas
d'excommunication
de l'Église de Nouvelle.
Et au regard
des expériences
que nous avons eues
avec cette personne,
il est facile aujourd'hui
dans nos circonstances
de comprendre,
d'avoir une image
de ce qu'est l'endurcissement
de cœur.
Lorsque nous voyons
une manifestation
volontaire
malgré l'éclairage
de la parole de Dieu,
une manifestation
volontaire
de l'endurcissement,
de la désobéissance,
lorsque nous voyons
une action manifeste
de la rébellion
contre Dieu,
en dépit du conseil,
en dépit des prières,
en dépit des années
et des années
d'enseignement
de la parole de Dieu.
Cependant,
nous aurions tort
de réduire
l'endurcissement à cela.
Nous aurions tort
de réduire
l'endurcissement
à des actions
menées contre Dieu.
Car ce n'est pas
de cette manière
que la Bible
commence par décrire
l'endurcissement.
Ce n'est pas
la perspective
ni de ce passage
ni de l'enseignement
de la parole de Dieu.
Alors,
qu'est-ce que l'endurcissement ?
Si ce n'est pas que,
bien que nous reconnaissons
que cela a été
de l'endurcissement,
mais si ce n'est pas
que des actions
volontaires
menées contre
la loi de Dieu,
qu'est-ce que
l'endurcissement ?
L'endurcissement
tel que nous partage
la parole de Dieu,
c'est l'événement
lorsque celui
qui est exposé
aux vertus de Dieu,
comme vous l'avez été
ce matin,
au travers de l'introduction,
au travers des chants,
au travers des prières,
celui qui est exposé
aux vertus de Dieu
ne répond pas
selon les attentes
de Dieu.
ne répond pas
selon les exigences
de Dieu.
Celui qui ne répond pas
aux attentes de Dieu
après avoir été exposé
aux vertus de Dieu
est déjà
un cœur endurci.
Celui qui est exposé
à la gloire de Christ
et qui ne travaille pas
à dédier plus sa vie
au service de Christ,
celui qui ne travaille pas
plus à sa sanctification,
plus à chérir Christ,
à connaître Christ,
est déjà
un cœur endurci.
Est déjà
sur la voie
de l'endurcissement.
Celui qui,
après avoir été exposé
à la gloire de Christ,
ne travaille pas plus
à faire de Dieu
ses délices,
n'est pas dans un simple
état d'indifférence.
Voilà des mots
que nous pouvons utiliser
par rapport à quelqu'un
qui sort,
selon nous,
inchangé
après l'exposition
de Christ.
mais la parole de Dieu
ne parle pas
de simple indifférence,
elle parle d'endurcissement
de cœur.
Et voilà notre état
si nous ressortons
sans agir
conformément
aux attentes de Dieu.
Donc,
en somme,
l'endurcissement
ne commence pas
lorsque nous menons
des actions
contre Dieu.
Lorsque nous faisons
des choses
contre Dieu,
l'endurcissement
commence déjà
lorsque nous ne faisons rien,
malgré l'exposition
des vertus de Christ.
Lorsque nous ne répondons pas
à l'exposition
de Dieu,
celui qui ne hâte pas
de conformer sa vie
après avoir été exposé
à la magnificence
de Dieu,
au regard de Dieu,
est déjà
sur la voie
de l'endurcissement.
Voilà en quoi
ce passage
est ultimement
pertinent
pour chacun d'entre nous.
le peuple
qui est exposé
à Christ
chaque semaine,
chaque jour
lorsque vous ouvrez
votre parole,
votre Bible,
la parole de Dieu.
Et pour montrer
que ce que je viens de dire
n'est pas
la définition
d'un prédicateur
à propos
de l'endurcissement,
je vous invite
à ouvrir
Romain 1
ensemble.
Nous allons
mieux comprendre
la définition
essentielle
de l'endurcissement
telle que présentée
par la parole de Dieu.
encore une fois
pour que nous puissions
comprendre la pertinence
de cet enseignement
pour nos vies.
Vous connaissez tous
Romain 1,
cette introduction
extraordinaire
d'un des plus grands
épîtres de la parole
de Dieu.
Et nous voyons ici
au verset 18
la colère de Dieu
se révèle du ciel
contre toute impiété
et toute injustice.
Des hommes
qui retiennent
injustement
la vérité captive.
Verset 19
Car ce qu'on peut
connaître de Dieu
est manifeste
pour eux
Dieu le leur
ayant fait connaître.
Verset 20
Et nous irons
jusqu'au verset 21
En effet,
les perfections
invisibles de Dieu,
sa puissance éternelle
et sa divinité
se voient comme
à l'œil nu
depuis la création
du monde
quand on les considère
dans ses ouvrages.
Ils sont donc
inexcusables
puisque
ayant tous
connu Dieu,
ils ne l'ont point
glorifié comme Dieu
et ils ne lui ont point
rendu grâce.
Autrement dit,
pourquoi Dieu
réserve sa colère ?
Dieu a réservé sa colère
contre toute injustice,
contre toute impiété.
Contre qui Dieu
va révéler sa colère ?
Dieu va réserver sa colère
dans ce passage
pour ceux
qui ont vu Dieu
dans la création,
ceux qui ont été témoins
de ce qu'on appelle
la révélation générale
de Dieu
et qui n'ont pas
répondu
conformément
à cette révélation.
Ceux qui n'ont,
selon le verset 21,
ceux qui l'ont connu
et qui ne l'ont point glorifié,
ceux qui ont vu Dieu
dans la création,
la merveille
de la création
et qui n'ont pas répondu
naturellement
en lui rendant grâce,
en le glorifiant.
Voilà
exactement
les personnes
contre Dieu,
contre qui Dieu
réserve sa colère.
Et
vous connaissez certainement
la liste des péchés
qui suit
au verset,
enfin,
dans ce chapitre,
la liste des péchés
que Dieu donne,
mais cela ne consiste pas
essentiellement
à l'endurcissement.
Cela est une conséquence
d'un endurcissement
déjà présent.
Nous voyons,
notamment verset 24,
c'est pourquoi,
en raison de leur
endurcissement,
parce qu'ils,
autrement dit,
parce qu'ils n'ont pas
glorifié Dieu,
parce qu'ils ne lui ont
pas rendu grâce,
c'est pourquoi,
verset 24,
Dieu les a livrés
à l'impureté.
Verset 26,
encore une fois,
parce qu'ils n'ont pas
connu Dieu,
parce qu'ils ne l'ont
point glorifié,
verset 26,
c'est pourquoi Dieu
les a livrés
à des passions infâmes.
La réponse naturelle
de chaque être humain,
contemplant raisonnablement
la création,
aurait été de glorifier,
et de servir Dieu,
de voir sa bonté.
Si un Dieu tout-puissant
a fait le monde
et que ce monde
est si appréciable,
c'est que ce Dieu
est bon.
et Dieu réserve sa colère
contre ceux qui n'ont pas
réagi conformément
à l'exposition
de ses vertus.
Voyons ensemble
dans Luc
comment cela est conforme
à l'enseignement
du Christ lui-même.
Je ne vais pas aborder
de manière exhaustive
tous ces passages,
j'en ai juste pris
quelques-uns,
pour que nous soyons
assurés
et pour que nous puissions
mieux examiner
notre cœur.
Luc,
au chapitre 17,
vous connaissez ce passage
où Jésus rencontre
dix lépreux
et Dieu guérit
les dix personnes.
Et nous lisons
Luc,
au chapitre 17,
au verset 13,
au 12b.
se tenant à distance,
ils élevèrent la voix
et dirent,
Jésus,
Maître,
aie pitié de nous.
Dès qu'il les eut vus,
il leur dit,
allez-vous montrer
au sacrificateur.
Et pendant qu'ils y allaient,
il arriva qu'ils furent guéris.
L'un d'eux,
se voyant guéri,
revint sur ses pas,
glorifiant Dieu
à haute voix.
Il tomba sur sa face
au pied de Jésus
et lui rendit grâce.
C'était un samaritain.
Jésus,
prenant la parole,
dit,
les dix n'ont-ils pas
été tous guéris
et les neuf autres,
où sont-ils ?
Ne s'est-il trouvé
que cet étranger
pour revenir
et donner gloire à Dieu ?
Puis il lui dit,
lève-toi,
ta foi t'a sauvé.
Pourquoi dans ce passage,
la perte des neuf autres
est presque assurée ?
En contraste avec
un homme
qui a été sauvé
par la foi.
Pourquoi selon ce passage,
Dieu,
ces neuf personnes,
partageront leur destinée
en enfer ?
Parce que,
après avoir été exposés
à la toute-puissance
de Dieu
dans leur corps,
après avoir été exposés
à l'office messianique
de Christ,
conformément
aux annonces
des prophètes
qu'il allait guérir
les malades,
après avoir été exposés
à toute-puissance,
l'office messianique
et la bonté de Dieu,
je vous rappelle,
ils ont crié
« Et pitié de nous ! »
Et Christ eut pitié d'eux.
Ils ont été exposés
aux vertus,
à des vertus
concernant Christ.
Et qu'est-ce que
Christ leur reproche ?
En réponse,
ils ne l'ont pas glorifié.
Voilà ce qui contraste
avec cet homme
qui sera sauvé.
Ces hommes ne seront pas sauvés
parce que,
ayant été exposés
à mes vertus,
ils ne sont pas revenus
pour me glorifier.
L'endurcissement
commence dans les choses
que nous ne faisons pas
en réponse
à l'exposition
des vertus de Dieu.
Et enfin,
retournons dans notre
passage à Hébreu.
Hébreu,
chapitre 2,
au verset 1.
Hébreu,
chapitre 2,
verset 1 à 3.
Et,
je vous rappelle,
ce matin,
en introduction,
nous avons lu
Hébreu,
chapitre 1.
Et Nathanael
nous a fait
une merveilleuse introduction
pour réveiller nos âmes
à la magnificence,
à la majesté de Christ,
l'être le plus admirable.
Et voilà comment
l'apôtre,
ici,
continue
après cette exposition
glorieuse de Christ.
Voyez cet avertissement.
Verset 1.
C'est pourquoi,
après avoir vu Christ,
après avoir vu la gloire
de Christ,
supérieure aux anges,
c'est pourquoi
nous devons
d'autant plus
nous attacher
aux choses que nous avons entendues,
de peur que nous ne soyons
emportés loin d'elles.
Verset 2.
Car si la parole
annoncée par des anges
a eu son effet,
et si toute transgression
et toute désobéissance
a reçu dans le passé
une juste rétribution,
comment échapperons-nous
en négligeant
un si grand salut ?
Voyez-vous ici
ce que Dieu risque
de reprocher
au peuple,
aux auditeurs
de cet épître,
c'est qu'après avoir
été exposés
à la magnificence
de Christ,
ils ont négligé
un si grand salut.
Au lieu de chérir
ce salut,
de connaître Dieu,
de se plonger
dans la connaissance,
dans la méditation
pour être enracinés,
ils ont négligé
un si grand salut.
Voilà l'endurcissement
tel que décrit
dans la parole de Dieu.
Voilà le début
de l'endurcissement
qui, bien évidemment,
se manifestera
par la suite
par des actions
volontaires menées
contre Dieu.
Mais voilà comment
Dieu voit le cœur
dur de l'homme,
le cœur endurci
de l'homme
à des personnes
qui ont été exposées
semaine après semaine
à l'enseignement
de la parole de Dieu,
à des personnes
qui depuis leur jeune âge
ont entendu
parler de Christ
et qui restent
apathiques
aux enseignements
de Dieu,
qui restent immobiles
face aux avertissements
que Dieu leur donne
et qui restent mous
face à l'exposition
glorieuse
des vertus de Christ.
Si ce matin,
nous nous unissons
à la prière de David
de sonder notre cœur,
que Dieu sonde
notre cœur,
eh bien nous devons
apprendre à voir
comment Dieu nous voit.
C'était la prière
de David.
Je veux voir,
Seigneur,
si mon cœur
est réellement durci.
Montre-moi mon cœur.
Et ce matin,
nous devons comprendre
quel est l'endurcissement
pour voir si nous-mêmes
nous ne sommes pas
endurcis
après avoir été exposés
aux enseignements
concernant Christ.
Comment avons-nous répondu
aux différents enseignements
que nous entendons ?
Voilà un point
que j'expliquais,
que je partageais
avec mon épouse hier.
La lettre aux Hébreux
et notamment
ses premiers chapitres,
on voit beaucoup
de parallélisme
dans les structures
du chapitre 2
et du chapitre 3
notamment.
Nous voyons
des structures similaires
se juxtaposer
les unes après les autres.
Qu'est-ce que nous voyons ?
Nous voyons chapitre 1,
la gloire de Dieu.
Chapitre 2,
un appel.
Comment vous devez répondre
après l'exposition ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on voit
ensuite au chapitre 2 ?
On voit la même chose,
l'exposition
de la gloire de Dieu.
Cette fois-ci,
non dans sa majesté,
mais dans la glorieuse
humiliation du Christ.
Et suite à cette exposition
de la gloire de Christ,
un appel.
Réajusté,
verset 1 du chapitre 3.
C'est pourquoi,
frère saint,
qui avait part
à la vocation céleste,
voilà l'ordre,
considérez l'apôtre
et le souverain
sacrificateur
de la foi
que nous professons.
Et suite à ce verset,
une autre exposition
de la gloire de Dieu,
Christ est supérieur
à Moïse.
Et ensuite,
l'appel que nous visons
aujourd'hui.
C'est pourquoi,
n'enjouissiez pas vos cœurs.
Et par ces parallélismes,
par ces structures similaires,
nous voyons que l'auteur
est en train de présenter
la même idée,
mais avec une nuance différente,
avec une approche différente.
La gloire de Dieu
considérée
avec un angle différent,
une facette différente.
Et nous voyons aussi
que les trois appels
qui sont présentés,
verset 1 du chapitre 2,
verset 1 du chapitre 3,
verset 7 du chapitre 3,
sont le même appel,
avec des nuances différentes,
avec une approche différente.
Donc,
si nous voulons comprendre
qu'est-ce que l'endurcissement,
nous devons aussi regarder
quels sont ces deux autres appels
qui sont des synonymes
de ces derniers appels.
Qu'est-ce que l'endurcissement ?
Eh bien,
relisons le verset 1 du chapitre 2,
qui constitue le premier appel
face à l'exposition
des vertus de Dieu.
Eh bien,
nous devons
d'autant plus
nous attacher
aux choses
que nous avons entendues.
Verset 1 du chapitre 3,
c'est pourquoi frère Saint,
qui avait part
à la vocation céleste,
considérait l'apôtre
et le souverain sacrificateur.
Verset 7 du chapitre 3,
c'est pourquoi,
aujourd'hui,
si vous entendez sa voix,
n'endurcissez pas vos cœurs.
Autrement dit,
qu'est-ce qu'endurcir son cœur ?
C'est négliger un si grand salut
et c'est ne pas considérer Christ
dans ses offices.
Dit de façon positive,
qu'est-ce que
ne pas endurcir son cœur ?
Eh bien,
c'est d'étudier Christ,
de chérir Christ,
de suivre Christ,
de se soumettre à Christ,
de prêter une vive attention
aux enseignements des Christ,
à méditer sur ses offices,
conformément
aux deux appels précédents.
Voilà pourquoi,
c'est une grâce
d'avoir été exposé ce matin
au chant,
à l'introduction,
mais c'est aussi
une grande responsabilité.
Car si,
après avoir été exposé
à l'enseignement de Dieu,
nous ne sommes pas plus dédiés
à vivre pour Dieu,
engagés à vivre pour Dieu,
si nous ne répondons pas
en étant déterminés
à glorifier Dieu
dans notre sainteté,
il se peut que nous soyons
déjà sur la voie
de l'endurcissement,
à cause des choses
que nous n'avons pas faites
en réponse
à l'exposition
des vertus de Dieu.
Voilà la définition
essentielle
de l'endurcissement.
Mais pour que nous puissions
comprendre la pertinence
de cet appel pour nous,
nous devons aussi comprendre
l'urgence de cet appel.
Comme je vous ai dit,
dans ces deux chapitres,
l'auteur à trois reprises
nous appelle.
À trois reprises,
il nous somme
de considérer Christ.
Et nous savons
que dans la Bible,
lorsque la Bible
utilise des répétitions,
elle le fait
pour insister
parce qu'elle sait
que nous avons un cœur
lent à comprendre,
pour mettre l'accent
sur quelque chose
d'extrêmement important.
Et ici,
en l'espace de deux chapitres,
l'auteur nous somme
à trois reprises.
C'est pourquoi,
prêtez une vive attention
à qui est Christ.
C'est pourquoi,
considérez Christ
l'apôtre
et le souverain
sacrificateur
de la foi
que nous professons.
Vous avez été exposés
à la majesté de Dieu,
répondez.
Vous avez été exposés
à la glorieuse humiliation
de Christ,
répondez.
Vous avez été exposés
à la supériorité de Christ
par rapport à Moïse,
n'endurcissez pas vos cœurs.
La répétition nous montre
l'importance
que Dieu accorde
à notre réponse.
Dieu n'est pas simplement
en train d'attendre
que nous répondions,
il exige que vous répondiez
à chacune des expositions
de ses vertus.
Et comme je l'ai dit précédemment,
ne serait-ce que par
ces répétitions,
nous pouvons comprendre
que le peuple
qui lit cette lettre
est un peuple
certainement apathique
également,
certainement mou,
à qui Dieu
a la volonté de répéter
« Quand répondras-tu
à l'exposition
de mes vertus ? »
Au sortir de chaque méditation
personnelle
de la parole de Dieu,
au sortir de chaque prédication,
n'attendons pas.
Obélissons à Christ
maintenant.
Et c'était aussi
pour revenir au psalmiste,
le désir du psalmiste
de voir le temps
comme Dieu le voit,
de voir sa vie
et ses jours
comme Dieu le voit,
pour être lui aussi
saisi d'urgence
et conformer sa vie.
Enseigne-moi, Seigneur,
à bien compter mes jours.
Nous pouvons trouver
au psaume 90.
Les jours
qui me sont destinés.
L'auteur voulait avoir
une meilleure perception.
Le psalmiste voulait avoir
une meilleure perception
qu'il avait
un montant de jours
qui lui étaient fixés
avant même
qu'il vint au monde.
Que ce montant de jours
défile à chaque réveil,
à chaque matin.
Et qu'il y aura
un jour
une limite
qu'il ne saurait franchir
lorsque Dieu
aura mené
sa vie à terme.
Et dans ces jours
qui sont destinés
par Dieu,
chaque jour
a un but.
Et soyez assurés
que le but
d'aujourd'hui
c'est de ne pas
endurcir votre cœur.
Aujourd'hui,
si vous entendez
sa voix,
n'endurcissez plus
votre cœur.
Cessons de perdre
notre temps.
Cessons de mener
dix années,
quinze années de vie
à l'écoute
de la parole de Dieu
sans chercher
à connaître mieux Christ,
à méditer,
à être fondé sur Christ,
à lui obéir,
à lui soumettre
notre vie.
Combien de temps
passerons-nous
à être des auditeurs
sourds,
nous qui avons été
exposés comme peut-être
aucune autre génération
à l'Évangile.
Nous devons comprendre
non seulement
l'urgence
de cet avertissement,
mais pour que nous puissions
crier de tout notre cœur
au Saint-Esprit
de nous aider
sur ce chemin
de l'endurcissement,
nous devons comprendre
aussi la profondeur,
la gravité
de l'endurcissement.
Comme nous avons vu,
nous sommes tous
concernés
par cet appel
dans son étendue.
Et si nous demandons
à Dieu,
Seigneur,
sonde mon cœur
pour voir si
moi qui me dis
simplement lassé
ou fatigué,
si je ne suis pas
sur une voie
d'endurcissement,
eh bien nous avons besoin
d'être saisis
par la gravité
de l'endurcissement
tel que Dieu
la voit lui-même.
Car c'est une chose
de refuser un appel,
c'est une chose
de refuser
une attente
de quelqu'un,
mais c'en est une autre
de mépriser
l'exposition
de l'être
le plus admirable
de l'univers.
Ceux qui connaissent
Hébreux,
comme nous l'avons
parcouru ensemble,
savent que
dans ces deux chapitres
et dans les chapitres
qui vont suivre,
l'auteur
utilise des exemples,
notamment
de l'Ancien Testament,
pour parler de Christ
par la chiste.
Il le fait
pour réveiller
l'attention
des auditeurs,
il le fait
pour que
la vision de Christ
soit plus compréhensible
pour nous,
mais nous voyons
qu'il utilise
ces exemples
passant de l'inférieur
au supérieur.
Autrement dit,
chapitre 1,
vous avez du mal
à comprendre
la majesté de Dieu,
vous avez du mal
à la concevoir,
eh bien je vais vous parler
des anges.
Vous comprenez
la grandeur des anges,
vous comprenez
la puissance des anges,
sachez
qu'à aucun ange
Dieu a dit
je suis ton père.
Sachez que
Christ est élevé
et supérieur aux anges,
de l'inférieur
au supérieur.
Chapitre 2,
vous comprenez,
vous avez du mal
à comprendre
la mesure,
l'infinitude
de la fidélité
de Christ.
Eh bien je vais vous parler
de Moïse,
car vous n'avez
aucun problème
à reconnaître
que Moïse
fut fidèle
dans la maison du Seigneur.
Eh bien sachez
que le père
a jugé plus digne
le ministère
de Christ
que celui de Moïse,
de l'inférieur
au supérieur.
Voilà le but
de ces exemples.
Et ici,
dans ce passage,
vous avez du mal
à comprendre
la gravité
de l'endurcissement,
vous avez du mal
à saisir
la gravité
de votre endurcissement,
eh bien je vais vous parler
de l'endurcissement
d'Israël.
Mais sachez
que votre endurcissement
est supérieur
à l'endurcissement
d'Israël,
de l'inférieur
au supérieur.
Votre endurcissement
est plus abominable
que celui
de vos pères.
Lisons à nouveau
chapitre 3
verset 7
à partir du
verset 8.
Aujourd'hui,
si vous entendez
sa voix,
n'endurcissez pas
vos cœurs,
comme lors
de la révolte,
le jour
de la tentation
dans le désert,
où vos pères
me tentèrent
pour m'éprouver
et ils virent
mes œuvres
pendant 40 ans.
Aussi,
je fus irrité
contre cette génération
et je dis,
ils ont toujours
un cœur
qui s'égare,
ils n'ont pas
connu mes voix.
Je jurais donc
dans ma colère,
ils n'entreront
pas dans mon repos.
Israël
a vu
le bras de Dieu
comme aucune
autre nation
n'a vu
le bras de Dieu.
Israël a vu
la main de Dieu
les secourir
comme aucune
autre nation
ethnique
n'a vu
la main de Dieu.
Israël a vu
l'oreille
attentive de Dieu
qui répondait
à ses supplications,
à ses cris
de détresse
comme aucune
autre génération
avant elle.
ils ont vu
la toute puissance
de Dieu
supérieure
aux autres dieux.
Ils ont vu
la sainteté
de Dieu
affichée
dans ses lois
et dans les malédictions
associées au péché.
Et non seulement
ils ont vu
la majesté,
la sainteté
de Dieu,
mais ils ont vu
la bonté
de Dieu,
le désir
que Dieu
avait de communier
avec son peuple
bien-aimé.
Dieu du ciel,
il règne en majesté
comme nous avons chanté
et descendu
sur cette montagne.
Oh oui,
le Dieu de l'univers
est descendu
s'approchant
de son peuple.
Et oui,
certes,
la nature a répondu,
la montagne a tremblé,
mais Dieu
est descendu
de son ciel
pour faire
connaître
à son peuple
son désir
de communier
avec lui.
Et Dieu
ne s'est pas arrêté
à sa montagne.
Dieu est descendu
au milieu du peuple,
dans un temple,
marchant avec son peuple
partout où il allait.
Ils ont vu
la majesté de Dieu
et ils ont vu
la douceur de Dieu,
son intention
clairement affichée
de communier
avec son peuple
et de les chérir.
Et malgré
l'exposition
des vertus de Dieu
du peuple d'Israël,
quelques jours plus tard,
ils contestèrent Dieu.
Quelques jours plus tard,
ils manquèrent
de le glorifier
en adorant
d'autres dieux.
Ils ont
bafoué
toutes les opportunités
que Dieu leur donnait
de l'obéir,
de le glorifier
comme réponse
tout à fait naturelle
d'un peuple
qui voit la main,
l'oreille de Dieu,
la sainteté,
la toute-puissance.
Et Dieu
ne manqua pas
de les châtir.
Pendant 40 ans,
il ne laissa pas
impunir
cet endurcissement
de ce peuple
qui a vu
des choses
telles qu'une nation
n'a jamais vu auparavant
et qui n'a pas
conformé sa vie,
qui n'a pas cherché
à glorifier
le seul et vrai Dieu.
Qu'est-ce qui est
réservé pour ce peuple ?
L'irritation
et la colère de Dieu
pour des gens
qui ont fait peu de cas
de l'exposition
de Dieu.
Cette génération
erra
pendant 40 ans.
Cette génération
fut frappée
à plusieurs reprises
par Dieu
et ultimement
cette génération
mourut
dans le désert
sans même
goûter au repos.
Dieu ne change pas.
Ses exigences
ne changent pas
envers son peuple.
Et précisément,
l'utilisation même
d'Israël
dans ce passage,
c'est la preuve
que le postulat
même de l'auteur
c'est de dire
que Dieu ne change pas.
Dieu ne change pas.
Et passant
de l'inférieur
au supérieur,
l'auteur
dit aux auditeurs
« Si Dieu
a frappé
vos pères
à cause
de leur endurcissement
après avoir été
exposés
à tant de vertus,
que pensez-vous
qu'il va devenir
de vous
si vous avez été
exposés
à Christ
et que vous
endurcissez
votre cœur ?
Car oui,
vous êtes plus
et nous sommes plus
éclairés
que la nation
d'Israël.
Israël
qui a vu
la main de Dieu,
les miracles
de Dieu,
qui a reçu
la loi,
les patriarches
et plus de détails
nous sont donnés
sur leurs privilèges
plus tard.
Israël
n'a eu droit
qu'au titre,
aux prophéties
annoncent Christ.
la Bible
nous dit
que même
les prophètes
dans l'Ancien Testament
ont attendu
ce jour
avec une grande impatience
et nous,
nous l'avons vu.
Nous avons vu
non seulement
le temple
où Dieu
demeurait
mais nous avons vu
Christ venir sur terre.
Nous avons vu
non seulement
les sacrifices
tels que décrits
dans l'histoire
mais nous avons vu
l'accomplissement
de tous ces sacrifices.
Dieu préserva
sa parole
pendant des siècles.
Dieu
a gouverné
l'histoire
pour que nous puissions
avoir la parole
de Dieu
dans notre foyer.
Soyez assurés
que vous avez été
éclairés
d'un éclairage
plus grand
que la nation d'Israël.
Si Dieu
a frappé vos pères
que pensez-vous
qu'il adviendra de vous ?
Voilà le principe
biblique
clairement exposé.
Celui qui reçoit
sera d'autant plus
redevable.
Je ne sais pas
si vous savez
le nombre de siècles
le nombre d'années
qu'il a fallu
pour qu'un chrétien
lambda
puisse avoir
la parole de Dieu
entre ses mains.
Nous sommes certainement
la génération
la plus exposée
facilement à l'évangile.
Et non seulement
à l'Ancien Testament
et à tout ce qui
a lancé Christ
mais aussi
à l'accomplissement
Christ lui-même
ainsi que l'histoire
de l'Église
qui nous atteste
de la véracité
de ces choses.
Jésus dit
Luc 12
un texte
que vous connaissez
certainement
qui montre
que celui
à qui il a été révélé
est d'autant plus
redevable devant Dieu.
Le serviteur
qui connaissait
la volonté
de son maître
et qui n'a rien préparé
qui n'a pas accompli
la volonté
de son maître
le recevra
un grand nombre
de coups.
Mais celui
qui ne la connaissait pas
et qui a mérité
ses coups
pour sa conduite
celui-là
n'en recevra
qu'un petit nombre.
À qui on a
beaucoup donné
on en demandera
beaucoup.
À qui on a
beaucoup confié
on réclamera
davantage.
C'est Jésus
qui parle.
Je suis venu
apporter un feu
sur la terre
et comme je voudrais
qu'il soit déjà allumé.
Voilà le Dieu
qui nous appelle
ce matin.
Voilà l'appel
que Dieu lance
au peuple
qui est rassemblé
pour écouter
sa parole
et l'exposition
de ses vertus.
Plus loin
l'auteur
ira même
écoutez
écoutez-moi bien
plus loin
l'auteur
ira même
à comparer
l'endurcissement
au fait
de fouler
au pied
Jésus-Christ.
Ce que nous avons
tendance à maquiller
par de la simple
indifférence
ou de la simple
tiédeur
l'auteur
plus loin
dira
vous avez
outragé
le sang
de l'Alliance
vous avez
méprisé
l'esprit
de la grâce
vous avez
foulé au pied
le Fils de Dieu
les trois personnes
de la Trinité
sont impactées
par votre endurcissement
vous avez
méprisé
les trois personnes
de la Trinité
si vous ne répondez
pas conformément
à l'attente
de Dieu
lorsqu'il expose
ses vertus
voilà
la profondeur
de l'endurcissement
la gravité
devant Dieu
de votre endurcissement
de notre endurcissement
et s'il est vrai
que notre endurcissement
équivaut
au fait
de fouler au pied
Jésus-Christ
après avoir été
exposé à sa bonté
exposé comme ce matin
à sa gloire
à sa majesté
que pensez-vous
de la colère
d'un père
lorsqu'il voit son Fils
être reflet au pied
que pensez-vous
qu'il adviendra
de vous
si vous méprisez
ses commandements
ses exhortations
si vous méprisez
les appels
clairs de Dieu
pour vous
si vous méprisez
de vous jeter
en lui
pour avoir
toute votre justice
voilà
la gravité
et au-delà
des conséquences
qu'Israël
a pu connaître
être frappé
erré
mourir dans le désert
ceux qui foulent
au pied
Jésus-Christ
n'auront
aucun repos
éternellement
ils erreront
et ils connaîtront
la mort
dans la forme
la plus douloureuse
angoissante
qui puisse être
puisque cette mort
durera éternellement
voilà la profondeur
de l'endurcissement
et à nouveau
pour que nous puissions
comprendre
la pertinence
de cet appel
ce matin
pour nous
nous devons comprendre
la nature
de l'endurcissement
l'urgence
de l'appel
de Dieu
la profondeur
de cet endurcissement
et également
qui
nous fait
cet appel
quelle est
l'autorité
de cet endurcissement
car ce matin
dans ce passage
solennel
et grave
que Dieu
nous appelle
nous communique
cet appel
de réponse
ne vient pas
d'un jeune
prédicateur
ne vient pas
non plus
seulement
d'un auteur
d'un épître
qui est en train
en plus
de citer le psalmiste
donc ça ne vient
même pas
du psalmiste
mais qu'est-ce que
nous dit l'auteur
ici
de manière très précise
verset 7
à nouveau
c'est pourquoi
selon ce que dit
le Saint-Esprit
voilà ce que l'auteur
est en train
d'essayer
de nous communiquer
il précise
précisément
que l'autorité
de cet appel
est conférée
à Dieu
lui-même
c'est Dieu
qui vous sommes
ce matin
à aujourd'hui
répondre
à l'exposition
de ses vertus
c'est Dieu
lui-même
qui vous invite
à prêter
une plus vive
attention
aux enseignements
de Christ
qui vous appelle
à considérer
Christ
et ses offices
aujourd'hui
et cela
au passage
petite parenthèse
est parfaitement
cohérent
avec le ministère
du Saint-Esprit
qui est écrit
par ailleurs
dans les écritures
le ministère
du Saint-Esprit
le Saint-Esprit
travaille
à guider
nos regards
vers les vertus
de Christ
le Saint-Esprit
oeuvre
pour que nous puissions
avoir constamment
les regards
fixés sur Christ
pour que nous puissions
être édifiés
en Christ
pour que nous puissions
vous puissiez
chérir Christ
voilà à quoi
vous pouvez reconnaître
le travail effectif
du Saint-Esprit
dans une église
chez des personnes
le Saint-Esprit
ne travaille pas
pour lui-même
le Saint-Esprit
n'est pas une force
qui est à rechercher
juste pour une expérience
personnelle
juste pour le Saint-Esprit
en soi-même
le Saint-Esprit
est là pour imprimer
dans votre coeur
les gloires
de Christ
tel que
la nouvelle alliance
qui nous est enseignée
dans Jérémie
il viendra
pour nous enseigner
pour imprimer
dans notre coeur
la loi de Dieu
pour nous enseigner
au sujet de Christ
et c'est ce que
Christ lui-même dit
au sujet du Saint-Esprit
si vous voulez reconnaître
si une église
si le Saint-Esprit
travaille dans une église
regardez si cette église
chère Christ
regardez si une église
cherche à connaître Christ
le Christ biblique
regardez ce que Jésus dit
dans Jean au chapitre 16
lui-même
en annonçant
le ministère du Saint-Esprit
Jean chapitre 16
au verset 13
quand le consolateur
sera venu
c'est à dire
l'esprit de vérité
il vous conduira
dans toute la vérité
et attention
car il ne parlera pas
de lui-même
le Saint-Esprit
n'opère pas
pour lui seul
de lui seul
et pour lui seul
il ne parlera pas
de lui-même
mais il dira
tout ce qu'il a
entendu
et il vous annoncera
les choses à venir
en somme
verset 14
il me glorifiera
parce qu'il prendra
ce qui est à moi
et il vous le communiquera
voilà le ministère
du Saint-Esprit
résumé dans ce verset
entre autres
parmi d'autres offices
le Saint-Esprit
est soumis au Fils
dans cette économie
de la Trinité
il est au service
du Fils de Dieu
pour que le croyant
puisse avoir
constamment
les regards fixés
sur Jésus Christ
donc
dans des milieux
où la connaissance
de Christ
ne grandit pas
où il n'y a
aucune soif
pour méditer
le Christ biblique
pour connaître
qui est Christ
où la vision
de leur Christ
s'éloigne toujours plus
de la vision béatifique
de Christ
nous pouvons remettre
en question
le travail du Saint-Esprit
dans ces milieux
malgré les expériences
qu'il puisse connaître
!
car voilà
le ministère
du Saint-Esprit
et ici
le Saint-Esprit
nous appelle
à nouveau
dans ce passage
à ne pas endurcir
notre cœur
ce qui est équivalent
à ce que nous avons vu
à considérer Christ
et à ne pas négliger
un si grand salut
Dieu
te parle
ce n'est pas
un jeune prédicateur
qui vous parle
Dieu
vous parle
selon ce que
le Saint-Esprit
vous dit
n'endurcis pas
vos cœurs
et il fait nul doute
que l'auteur ici
fasse la mention
de Dieu
que c'est Dieu
qui parle
pour que vous puissiez
avoir la sainte révérence
en écoutant cet appel
aujourd'hui
si tu entends sa voix
n'endurcis pas ton cœur
quel que soit le domaine
évidemment
ici
il est en premier lieu
question du salut
de la foi
dans l'office suffisant
et parfait de Christ
mais aujourd'hui
vous-même
si vous entendez sa voix
n'endurcissez pas vos cœurs
quelles que soient vos circonstances
quelle que soit la manière
dont Dieu
expose ses vertus
répondez conformément
à l'exposition
de la majesté du Dieu
en soumettant votre vie
en apprenant
à lui faire confiance
en arrêtant de compter
sur votre propre justice
que ce soit pour votre fierté
ou pour votre propre misère
c'est-à-dire
ceux qui
sentent que le salut de Christ
est trop loin
de leur péché
et bien aujourd'hui
saisissez le salut de Christ
n'endurcissez pas vos cœurs
nous devons
lorsque nous comprenons
qui est l'auteur
de cet appel
l'auteur véritable
nous devons mesurer
!
lire avec vous
certains passages
de personnes
dans la Bible
à qui Dieu
a parlé
ou à qui Dieu
s'est momentanément révélé
quelles étaient leurs réactions
tout à fait raisonnables
et naturelles
Exode chapitre 19
verset 16
lorsque Dieu
se communique
à son peuple
nous voyons les dix commandements
en ce moment
Dieu du ciel
descend dans sa bonté
sur la montagne
réaction du peuple
verset 16
tout le peuple
qui était dans le camp
se mit à trembler
voilà la réponse naturelle
d'un peuple
qui a conscience
qu'il se tient devant Dieu
la réponse
des choses animées
et même inanimées
verset 18
la montagne
tremble
avec violence
cela est confirmé
même par les psaumes
où David nous dit
que la terre
le voit
et tremble
à la vision de Dieu
à la compréhension
que Dieu
se tient devant eux
et parle
comment Moïse réagit
lorsque Dieu lui parla
au milieu du buisson
Exode 3
Moïse se cache à le visage
car il craignait
de diriger ses regards
vers Dieu
comment Isaac réagit
lorsque Dieu lui parla
Isaac
Genèse 18
Isaac se prosterna
à terre
comment Josué réagit
lorsque le chef
de l'armée de l'éternel
se tient devant lui
Josué 5
Josué tomba le visage
contre terre
il se prosterna
comment Esaïe réagit
lorsqu'il a la vision
glorieuse
de Dieu dans son temple
Esaïe chapitre 6
malheur à moi
car mes yeux
ont vu le roi
comment Jean Baptiste
a réagi
lorsqu'il aperçut
de loin
Jésus Christ
s'avance envers lui
voici la mieux de Dieu
venu pour ôter
le péché de l'humanité
voilà des réactions
tout à fait naturelles
que Dieu exige
de nous
lorsqu'il expose
ses vertus
comment
pouvons-nous
rester insensibles
devant la parole
de Dieu
comment nous
nous pouvons rester
debout
lorsque Dieu
nous parle
comment
lorsque Dieu
vous reprend
de manière si claire
au travers
des prédications
que nous avons
entendues dernièrement
lorsque Dieu
vous parle
au sujet
de votre sanctification
de la repentance
du pardon
de la paix
comment
répondons-nous
à la parole
de Dieu
lui-même
quelle perception
avons-nous
de Dieu
qui nous parle
nous avons besoin
de demander
de supplier
le Saint-Esprit
pour que la perception
de Dieu
puisse être plus grande
dans notre coeur
lorsque Dieu nous parle
non seulement ici
le dimanche
mais à chaque fois
que vous ouvrez
la parole de Dieu
car voilà des réponses
celles que j'ai lues
des réponses
tout à fait appropriées
à quelqu'un qui comprend
qui se tient devant Dieu
comment nous
dans quelle mesure
pouvons-nous évaluer
la dureté de notre coeur
lorsque nous entendons
prédication sur prédication
exposition de la gloire de Dieu
sur exposition
de la gloire de Dieu
et que nous repartons
sans changer
rien dans notre vie
sans chercher
à être plus discipliné
à connaître Dieu
à vivre la communion fraternelle
à prier
à lire la parole de Dieu
à être édifié
en Christ
la forme écrite
de la Bible
ne doit pas oublier
que derrière
il y a un auteur
qui est zélé
un auteur
qui est animé
de grandes émotions
et ici
par la répétition
à trois reprises
de cet appel
dans le chapitre 2 et 3
nous devons savoir
qu'il y a derrière
ces lettres
l'amour d'un père
pour son peuple
n'endurcissez pas
vos coeurs
aujourd'hui
prêtez
une vive attention
aujourd'hui
considérer Christ
combien de temps
vas-tu encore perdre
considère Christ
son office
son apostolat
le Dieu de l'univers
t'appelle à considérer
son fils
à te confier
pleinement lui
il te parle
à toi personnellement
et à te saisir
de sa justice
et enfin
dans cet appel
solennel
et grave
dans cet appel
presque
oppressant
et ténébreux
pour nos âmes
lorsque nous considérons
que nous sommes
probablement
sur la voie
de l'endurcissement
et que cet endurcissement
a une gravité
extrême
devant Dieu
que l'auteur
veut nous communiquer
par l'exemple
d'Israël
et bien dans cet avertissement
nous voyons toutefois
la générosité
de Dieu
l'éclat
de la générosité
de Dieu
qui brille
dans un appel
aussi grave
pourquoi ?
dans la parole de Dieu
nous trouvons
quelques mots
qui sont extrêmement
importants
lorsque vous étudiez
lorsque vous interprétez
les écritures
des mots
qu'il faut souligner
entourer
qui font le lien
entre différentes sections
et qui nous permettent
de mieux situer
l'intention de l'auteur
dans son contexte
et ici
quel est ce mot
si important ?
c'est pourquoi ?
pourquoi ce mot
est si important
pour nous ?
parce que l'appel
que Dieu vient
de vous lancer
l'appel
et la gravité
qui vient de vous démontrer
exposé dans votre coeur
cet appel là
n'est pas isolé
Dieu
ne nous ordonne pas
sans nous communiquer
aussi les raisons
légitimes
raisonnables
de lui obéir
vous ayant partagé
la gloire de Christ
vous ayant
partagé
la supériorité de Christ
par rapport à Moïse
obéissez
Dieu n'attend pas de nous
que nous sortons
de ce culte
et que nous obéissons
de manière légaliste
dépourvue
de sentiments
et d'affection
Dieu attend de nous
une obéissance
de Puyala
Dieu attend de nous
que nous réagissions
notre être entier
impliqué
dans l'obéissance
dans la recherche
de qui Christ est
voici pourquoi
pour vous
qui êtes lassés
fatigués
qui vous sentez
avec un manque
de zèle
pour les choses de Dieu
et qui êtes
opprimés
par la lecture
de ces attentes
et des exigences
de Dieu
nous pouvons être
encouragés
par ce
c'est pourquoi
parce que ce
nous montre
que Dieu
est déterminé
à pallier
notre faiblesse
ce c'est pourquoi
est là pour nous
communiquer
que si nous
manquons d'affection
Dieu a l'intention
de nous communiquer
abondamment des choses
à son sujet
Dieu nous montre
son intentionnalité
en pourvoyant
pour nous
pour notre propre
cœur
des riches motivations
si ton cœur
est sec
manque de zèle
je suis ton Dieu
qui va te communiquer
de riches motivations
pour que tu puisses
m'adorer
pour que vous ne doutiez
pas de l'intentionnalité
de Dieu
de se faire connaître
à vous personnellement
comme nous avons vu
dans Romain 1
la révélation générale
Dieu aurait pu
se contenter
de la révélation générale
pour exiger
que l'humanité
considère sa création
sa toute puissance
sa divinité
son éternité
et l'adore
mais Dieu
allait plus loin
que cette révélation générale
Dieu a communiqué
sa parole
de manière écrite
qui a traversé
les âges
les continents
pour que vous
ce matin
qui possédez
la parole de Dieu
puissiez recevoir
de profondes motivations
pour adorer Dieu
soyez assurés
que Dieu
vous est favorable
que si Dieu
votre endurcissement
que vous reconnaissez
la gravité
de votre endurcissement
devant Dieu
face à votre
non réponse
à l'exposition
de ses vertus
soyez assurés
que Dieu
a l'intention
de se faire connaître
à celui qui le demande
que celui
qui le cherche
Dieu le demande
le trouvera
voilà pourquoi
nous avons passé
tant de temps
à étudier
qu'est-ce que
l'endurcissement
pour que nous puissions
être convaincus
que cela peut être
la voie de chacun
d'entre nous
pour que nous puissions
appeler secours
à Dieu
de tout notre coeur
considérant la dureté
de notre coeur
mais soyez
assurés
de l'intention
de Dieu
vous voyez
Dieu
comme nous avons dit
dans le ciel
avec le peuple d'Israël
descendant
manifestant sa
condescendance
en descendant
sur cette montagne
en manifestant
son intention
de communier
avec son peuple
en descendant
maintenant
dans le temple
voyez Dieu
pour nous
qui n'est plus
dans un temple
mais qui est descendu
lui-même
sur terre
s'approchant
encore plus
de ses créatures
se faisant
l'un des leurs
voyez Dieu
maintenant
voulant nous assurer
de son intentionnalité
à se faire connaître
vivant
en nous
voyez
quelle condescendance
Dieu a eue
pour que vous soyez
assurés
que Dieu
est en votre faveur
veut que vous
le connaissiez
Dieu est descendu
de son trône
de gloire
Dieu habite
maintenant
dans notre coeur
et si nous
crions à lui
lorsque nous
constatons
notre endurcissement
soyons assurés
que celui
qui le cherche
Dieu le trouvera
nous devions
si nous le cherchons
vraiment
nous devrions
être là
où Dieu
nous offre
des opportunités
de le connaître
la méditation
dans la discipline
chaque jour
Dieu se laissera
trouver par celui
qui chaque jour
cherche à le connaître
les vendredis soirs
où la parole
de Dieu
est clairement exposée
où nous prions
les uns pour les autres
Dieu est là
Dieu désire
se faire connaître
à chacun d'entre vous
nous devrions même
sacraliser ces moments
d'une certaine façon
vivre notre semaine
en fonction de ces moments
saisir toutes les opportunités
gracieuses
généreuses de Dieu
qu'il nous a donné
pour se faire connaître
à notre coeur
voilà le rempart
contre l'endurcissement
et
j'introduis juste
la suite
de ce passage
où l'auteur
va nous donner
des moyens
très concrets
pour lutter
contre l'endurcissement
de coeur
où il mentionnera
entre autres
la communion fraternelle
comme puissant
rempart
contre l'endurcissement
Dieu
vise
à nourrir
ton âme
à son sujet
Dieu cherche
à ce que tu te plonges
dans ses bras
que tu te saisisses
de sa propre justice
que tu arrêtes
de vivre
soit par ta piété
soit dans ton
misérabilisme
mais que tu comptes
sur la justice
suffisante
de Christ
vous savez certainement
que lorsque nous serons
glorifiés
nous aurons cette vision
béatifique de Christ
et vous savez certainement
que cela constituera
notre
notre activité principale
la considération
de Christ
dans toute sa gloire
nous serons
dépourvus
de péché
la révélation
sera d'autant plus claire
de nos yeux
et nous ne nous lasserons
pas de contempler Christ
de chérir Christ
de plonger
nos regards
de Christ
rien de plus attirant
ne pourra nous distraire
de cette activité principale
tout comme les anges
le font
aujourd'hui
en ce moment même
mais nous ne devrions
pas attendre
d'être dans la gloire
pour commencer
cette activité
si nous sommes
s'achetés
nous sommes appelés
saumés par Dieu
ce matin
à ne pas endurcir
notre coeur
face à
l'exposition
déjà présente
des vertus de Dieu
ainsi
lorsque nous sortirons
de ces moments
que chacun d'entre nous
puisse prendre
la sévérité
de cet appel
la gravité
l'autorité
de cet appel
et puisse chercher
de tout son coeur
après l'introduction
après les chants
après les prières
que vous avez entendues
à répondre
selon les exigences
de Dieu
car Dieu
voit cet endurcissement
d'une grande gravité
et que nous puissions
nous joindre
à la prière de Paul
ou au verset de Paul
je considère
tout comme une perte
pour l'excellence
de la connaissance
de Jésus Christ
Amen